i Salam alaikum guys how are you doing I
just met Ken are you doing good we see
this happening so so much now when the
purpose of life is on the minds of the
person and they're searching they find
it in this way of life you found it and
now this was how long about three months
ago yeah your former christian jealously
jehovah's witness tell us what attracted
you about islam that had you accepted so
what attracted me about islam was
basically i started to research upon the
three holy books of the Torah the
gospels little at the time so in the
conclusion i started to research that in
every language there is rules the set of
rules on how to build a sentence
paragraph and when you translate a book
like the gospels from Hebrew to Spanish
to English what is supposed to be the
Word of God
changes from one language to another
because the rules are different so I
considered that the Bible
the Gospels to Torres it was tempered
because it was also brought up in an era
where politics were being born so it
could have been manipulated by men for
the people to do as the Roman Empire
wanted at that time and after reading
upon the can on also I came to the
conclusion that since the Quran has been
in the exact original context for 1440
something years it was a for me I
considered that the Word of God because
the Word of God is perfect shall not be
changed never and I felt that Islam for
me was the truth
and I felt like I was in peace the
moment I stepped in in a mushroom and I
felt that that was where I belong and
yeah I converted yeah many people don't
know that when we say Torah as Muslims
we believe in the original what was
given to Moses but you don't have that
today
yeah injeel was given to jesus peace be
upon him and it's original but we don't
have that today but took her on tamper
free tamper proved you could put it to
the test as it was revealed and it's
guaranteed that it hasn't been tampered
with corrupted God Almighty tells us in
the Quran
FLA after that burden and do they not
consider the time had it been from other
than the Creator Allah you would find in
it many discrepancies contradictions you
put it to the test and we didn't find
that yeah you found it to be authentic
and now how long were you were you
originally your parents with your home
as witness or so are you practicing
Jehovah's Witness yeah so our job is
witness the ones that they write on the
bikes um they go to your house on a
Saturday they drunk were you on the
bikes going the door that's all I was
not very religious I was born in a
really Orthodox family and I hated being
a Jehovah's Witness I hated religion I
hated all those turn why did you hate it
here for one because it was the way that
they put everything in my life if I did
a decision they would may they'd seem
like I was going to hell for making that
decision if I talked to a Christian to a
Jewish to a Muslim they'll tell me that
I would go to hell and for me
what do you mean if you just talk to me
like had a normal dialogue because they
know that they know that I could easily
convert to another village and so they
want to prevent always really restricted
to its respect in communication with
other people of other phrase have India
okay so after all of this I grew up kind
of rebel towards religion and I never
felt like I belonged until I did the
Shahada three-month
and results of all of this became that
my family decided to basically expel me
from my family from the religion and it
wasn't until three weeks ago that I am
now living with a host family
Palestinian host family and because of
what they believe in they for them it's
it's crazy to have a son that is a
Muslim but it's a so-called terrorist
and that's how some of them view Muslims
like that's how social media puts it all
so for them it wasn't good they said
that I was changing that I was they said
a lot of bad things and they told me
well you have this certain time to leave
your house your parents and I left tell
us for those people may God Almighty
Allah reunite you with your parents God
willing they maybe they see this or
others and they realized what Islam is
all about that is truly a way of life
from the crater helping to be helping
every individual who wants to be a
better human being giving you the game
plan how to do that to be kind and
merciful to your parents to your
neighbors to be the best morally upright
righteous person you can be we're all
going to fall short make mistakes but
Islam gives you that blueprint what
advice do you have for people out there
who now they're also seeking purpose but
there's all this stigma attached to
Islam all terrorism oppression of women
all this other nonsense you got through
that what advice do you have for other
people stuck in that rut just like the
angel told the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him exa we'd read learn
every Muslim is supposed to have
knowledge every person in general
non-muslim Muslims so I recommend to
read don't believe what CNN Fox News
Twitter Instagram puts out about Muslim
I thought the same I was ignorant I
thought that they were bad people I felt
scared at first then meeting these
Muslims meeting going to I offend that's
my mustard seeing how they were how they
treated me how they treated other how
they put everyone else first and they're
the last one
that was something meaningful to me
because I started to see for the first
time what was unity for the first time
so read do your research and a crap read
that's great advice
pick up the Quran read it put it to the
test make the human connection talk to a
Muslim one who is really living this way
of life and visit us here at the Deen
show or even here we're at the game T's
booth here at Mass acknow will bring you
more so I'm alaikum
thank you for sharing that so I'm a COO
and you're pretty young how old are you
I'm 20 years old 20 years old man more
people would also really reflect and
think how do we get here why are we here
where are we going this young man was
contemplating thinking he found it in
his Deen submission to the will of the
creator not the creation Islam peace
lawmaking